[موسيقى]
من منا لا يتابع ولو بدرجات متفاوته احدى
منصات التواصل الاجتماعي جميعنا نفعل ذلك
ولو لدقائق في اليوم قد يكون ذلك رغبه في
معرفه الجديد ما يجري في العالم او هربا
من واقع صعب الى اخر قد يبدو اكثر راحه او
لمجرد الترفيه عن النفس او بدافع الفضول
فقد باتت التواصل جزءا من حياتنا بل انها
الحياه نفسها عند البعض يعرضون عليها
الدقه تفاصيل يومياتهم ويشاركونها مع
الاخرين متابعه واعجابا وتفاعلا هي نقله
فوريه في عالم الاتصال بين البشر اذ لم
يعد الانسان معها ذلك المتلقي السلبي الذي
يستقبل ما تبثه وسائل الاعلام والاتصال
التقليديه بل باتم متفاعلا اولا مع ما
يتلقاه ومنتجا ايضا للمعرفه والترفيه
ومعبرا عما يجول في نفسه بحريه ودون مقيود
اكثر من اللزوم في كثير من الاحيان
تطبيقات التواصل هذه يستخدمها عبر قرابه
خمسه مليارات انسان ومنصه فيسبوك لوحدها
استخدمها نحو 230 مليون شخص في العالم
العربي ومن بين ملايين المستخدمين
ظهر من يوصفون بالمؤثرين يقدمون محتوى
يجذب متابعين كثر ويتفاعلون معه مدحا
وقدحا ولا يحققون شهره فقط بل ايضا مكاسب
ماليه قد تكون طائله ولم يخلو النظر الى
الظاهره من جدل حول ايجابياتها وسلبياتها
خاصه بالنسبه للاطفال والمراهقين وتحذيرات
من تاثيراتها على الصحه العقليه حتى
للبالغين نتلمس جانبا من هذا الجدل في
قصتنا الليله منصات التواصل الضريبه
المتابعه وذلك مع ثلاثه من مشاهير منصات
التواصل يقدمون محتويات مختلفه منها
الكوميدي ومنها ما يتعلق بالسفر والرحلات
ومنها ما يمزج بين المعرفي والتجارب
الحياتيه نناقش معهم ومع خبراء ايجابيات
وس استخدام مواقع التواصل وامكانيات
الحفاظ على قيم الخصوصيه فيها ونعرض
دراسات تحذر من اصابه مستخدمي هذه المواقع
بمشاعر الاكتئاب والوحده نستكمل بقيه
القصه مع ضيفين الدكتور اشرف محمد الصالحي
مستشار الطب النفسي وعلاج الادمان
والدكتوره ميال عبد الله استاذه في علوم
الاعلام والاتصال في كليه الاعلام في
الجامعه اللبنانيه نسال ضيفين الكريمين عن
مدى التغيير الذي تحدثه مواقع التواصل في
حياه الناس اجتماعيا ونفسيا والى اي حد
تؤثر في تشكيل اهتمامات المتابعين خاصه من
المراهقين وعن امكانيه فرض ضوابط على
المحتوى الاجتماعي لكن ما رايكم ان نشاهد
القصه بدايه وبعدها الحوار
[موسيقى]
شغلي
شو اخباركم
[موسيقى]
قرابه خمسه مليارات شخص حول العالم
يستخدمون وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي اليوم
من عام 2023 ومن المتوقع ان يصلوا الى سته
مليارات عام 2027 ففي المنطقه العربيه
يقدر عدد مستخدمي فيسبوك وحده بحوالي 230
مليون مستخدم لعام 2022 شكل هذا الانتشار
الواسع لتلك الشبكات فرصه لبعض الشباب
والمراهقين للقفز الى الشخصيه المثاليه
التي يحلمون بها بعيدا عن الشخصيه
الواقعيه فانتشر الاغتراب والانفصال عن
الواقع
وسائل تواصل اجتماعي فرضه واقع يعيش فيه
متابع المحتوى على هذا على هذه الوسائل
ويتفاعل معه ويعتقد بانه حقيقي ويتابعه
ويقرر الاعتماد عليه هذا بشكل او باخر ادى
الى
فصل بين الحياه الواقعيه والحياه على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ضريبه المتابعه
محاوله فرض قيم معينه
موجوده لدى هذا المحتوى موجوده لدى
المؤثرين على الحياه الخاصه
للمتابعين
[موسيقى]
السوشيال ميديا من جتا انها سهله
الاستخدام
لا تشترط مستوى ثقافي عالي تختصر المسافات
ترسل بحث الف صفحه في دقيقه واحده
تستطيع ان تقرا كتب ومؤلفات وتعود الى
التاريخ وفيديوهات هذا شيء مفيد وشيء مهم
لكن ايضا على قاعده ان لكل شيء وجه وجه
سلبي من احد الاوجه السلبيه لهذه الوسائل
انها غيرت في نمط الحياه
بلاش اول شيء ماساتي مع الانترنت سوشيال
ميديا مع اولاده لما نبلش يسهروا كتير
لحتى انيمهم ما بيناموا يا ماما بدنا نحضر
بدنا نشوف بدنا نستطلع اكثر شيء ابني
الكبير
كملت مع بنته صغيره عمرها سبع سنين صارت
تعمل حركات مثل الفنانين مثل ما بيعملوا
ترندات وبتتحمر وبتتكحل
المرايه وتحكي مع حالها
من وراء التيك توك وخبريات التيك توك كنا
احنا جونا العامه ما بيمشي الحال معنا هيك
قصص
[موسيقى]
تحفز وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي المستخدمين
على الساع لرفع اعداد المتابعين وزياده
المشاهدات مقابل الشهره وتصاعد الارباح
هذه الخصائص افرزت ما بات يعرف بمشاهير
السوشيال ميديا
ظهرت جدليه الفوائد مقابل الاضرار لما
ينشره المشاهير من محتوى يوصف بعضه
بالهاادف والمفيد واخر بانه ذو اثر سلبي
لرصد هذه الظاهره قابلنا ثلاثه شخصيات من
مشاهير السوشيال ميديا وهم ادم وزوجته
ايزابيل اللذان اتخذ من الاسفار حياه لهم
فعليا عايشين السفر
[موسيقى]
بعض مشاهير المنصات الاجتماعيه لمشاركه
واتاحه حياتهم الشخصيه للمتابعين ونشر
تفاصيلها
ورغم تنوع المحتوى على مواقع التواصل تحظى
هذه المنشورات بتفاعل اكبر مدفوعا بفضول
المتابعين لمعرفه تفاصيل ما يجري في بيت
المشهور ما اشعل جدلا حول اثار هذا الكشف
عن الخصوصيات ودور مواقع التواصل
والمشاهير بالترويج لها لدى شرائح
المتابعين
[موسيقى]
مشاركه حياتنا الخاصه
صراحه ما تكذب علي يعني موضوع صعب كثير
صعب يعني وهذا بتحس لحظه حلوه بدنا طعمه
اسوارات وتعمل بوست انستغرام بس كمان نحن
عنا لحظات مو هيك حلوين لهيك انا نحن كمان
نزل هذول الشغلات وبهذه موضوع واحد بتحس
يعني بتحس هيك صغير بتحس عندي مشكله وهي
اللحظه يعني اذا حدا بيقول شي عنجد فيني
تعمل هيك تمام يعني احنا بنكون بمود حلو
واحيانا تكون كتير تعبانين
كتير يعني فممكن حدا يستغل هاي الفكره انه
كلمه يجنننا يعني دايقنا كتير
[موسيقى]
هيك انه احنا يعني حياتنا متاحه لانه احنا
بصراحه احنا كثير كثير عرفانين شو نطلع
وشو ما نطلع عم بحكي
ما بعرف البقايا في بعضهم بيروحوا اكستريم
الصراحه بس انا من ناحيتي
[موسيقى]
هذا شيء خاص مغلق مفترض ان يبقى كذلك
مشاهير عندما يعرض صور من حياتهم الشخصيه
يعرضوا الصور الايجابيه
الجميله اللطيفه وهم يخفوا الجانب الاخر
وهو موجود يعني المشاهير يقوم بعمليه
تضليل مقصوده او غير مقصوده
للنموذج الذي يعيشونه والاخر يعتقد ان هذا
هو النموذج الواقعي هذا نموذج غير واقع
يعني مشكله بين التضليل وبين الواقع هذا
هو الفرق
لطالما شكلت الصوره المثاليه والبراقه
التي يقدمها بعض المشاهير فجوه لدى
المتابعين الذين ربما يعيشون واقعا مغايرا
ورغم ان ذلك قد يعزى الاختلافات في واقع
البلدان ومستويات المعيشه وطبيعه الحياه
لكن جزءا كبيرا يتهم بتقديم صوره مزيفه او
منفصله عما تعيشه العربيه
بنفس الوقت مشهور يعني على السوشيال ميديا
راح تكون يعني عليك مضاعف عشرات عشرات
الاضعاف على المشاهير من الجنسيات الثانيه
فاذا انا صورت حالي قاعده جنب الفاير بليس
هذا اسمه يعني
شوفه حال ورفاهيه زايده عن اللزومبل
[موسيقى]
واحد الريل يعني بيعرفوا للعالم
لابسين براندات بس موبايل
بجيبوا
لابسين مره واحده وبرجعه
انه تعرفنا على صبيه بنحكي معها من زمان
على السوشيال ميديا وهي مشهوره كثير يعني
باوروبا فلما رحنا شفناها بالبلد اللي
عايشه فيه صدمنا كليا غير شخص
فلاتر ثياب ستايل كل شي مختلف
اكتر عدو ليك انت بالضبط
او لعياء وبغيت التليفون ويتفرج في هذا
انني ما نوصلش للناس ان الحياه اللي كنعيش
هي حياه مثاليه وحياه اللي واعره بالعكس
خاصني نكون انا هو نقطه الضوء اللي نقدر
نحفزك ونقول لك هذاك الشيء اللي كادير في
حياتك تقدر توصل له نكون انا هو الحافز
ديالك ماشي هو المصدر ديال الاكتئاب ديالك
انا شخصيا كنشوف باللي بعض المشاهير اللي
كينفصلوا على الواقع اوتوماتيكيا حاجه
كتجي هكا ومع الوقت
[موسيقى]
بتصدر عن وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي نفسها
مثل يوتيوب
وانستجرام وتيك توك وفيسبوك ويلي بتحكي عن
المقاطع والمحتوى الاكثر رواجا في العالم
العربي خلال السنوات الماضيه كلها بتاكد
انه المحتوى اللي كان اكثر رواجا هو اللي
يندرج تحت قطاع الترفيه سواء كان فكاهي او
تحديات او نمط حياه المشاهير
بحث مسرب لفيسبوك عنوانه المقارنه
الاجتماعيه على انستغرام نشرته صحيفه
وورستي جورنال اظهر ان متابعين نجوم مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي يعانون من المشاعر
السلبيه المرتبطه بصوره الذات فيما كشفت
دراسه اخرى اجرتها شركه بيوري سيرش
الامريكيه المتخصصه بدراسات مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي ان 71% من مستخدمي وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي يشاهدون محتوى يجعلهم
غاضبين فيما يعاني 49% من الاكتئاب ويشعر
واحد وثلاثون بالمئه بالوحده بعد مشاهده
محتوى ما
[موسيقى]
مرحبا يا حلوين اهلا وسهلا فيكم ورمضان
كريم وينعاد عليكم وعلى اهلكم بالخير
والصحه الناس تعرف انه شو محتوانا فالكابس
متابعه متوقع شو يشوف في ناس تحبط اكيد بس
بتوصل لمرحله انه لازم تتحرك على حالها
كيف نحن بلشنا شغلنا اونلاين بعتقد نحن
الناس كتير استفادت والناس المحبطه يعني
كمان عم تقدم لهم حاول خيارات شو ما كان
جنسيتك شو مكان دخلك قادر تسافر قادر
تنبسط قادر تلحق حلمك قادر تعيش بحب
يعني ما بعرف عن جد لوين رايحين ما بعرف
ليه هالاولاد كثير عم بيحبوا تقمصوا
شخصيات هن مش قدها ما بعرف هذا الواقع
اللي نحن وصلنا له من ولد سوشيال ميديا
بنشوف الاشياء حلوه كثير وانا نصلى ونحن
مش قادريننا يعني هذا الشيء المبهرج شيل
مزين الملون ما نحن قدرتنا هالقد بدنا ننط
عنا ليه
الشعور الغضب ده كان بيجيلي ودائما بحس
انه انه انا يا ريتني مكانها ياريتني عندي
اللي هي اللي هي عند عايرتني عندي عدد
الفلورز اللي عندها مثلا بس بيكون شعور
انه انا حاسه ان انا اقل من الناس اللي
حواليا في ناس كتير جدا ممكن تكون سبقاني
في حاجات في اهداف معينه هما يعني اولادي
يوصلوا لها وانا ما وصلتلهاش ممكن يكون
ناس ثانيه عايشه طريقه حياه تانيه انا
يعني ايه مش عارفه اقارن نفسي خالص بيها
ولما بقارن نفسي بلاقي ان انا اذا انا
حياتي كلها يعني ما فيهاش اي حاجه من اللي
هم عايشينه وانا حياتي ملهاش لازمه
متى يخرب منطقه تفكير يخرب طريقه التعامل
مع الحياه الحقيقيه يعني هو يصير يفكر انه
سيترك كل شيء لينتقل للعيش في هذا الفندق
او هذا المنتجع السياحي او في هذا البلد
الجميل الحين انه الواقع ليس كذلك هذا
يمكن ان يؤدي بالمئات او بالالاف الى ان
يترك كل شيء هذه هي الخطوره التي قد تحصل
لدى فئات محدده من الشباب او من الشابات
خوارزميات وسائل تواصل اجتماعي المختلفه
دائما بتسعه لانه تخلي المستخدم يبقى فتره
اطول في هذه الوسائل سواء كانت فيديوهات
ولا صور او معلومات المهم بالنسبه لهذه
الخوارزميه هي جذب المستخدم لقضاء وقت
اطول حسب عدد من الاحصائيات ومنها مؤسسه
المحتوى يلي عم ينشاف في العالم العربي
رايح اكثر
للترفيه رايح اكثر للتسليه هذا الشيء ربما
يكون في له اثار سلبيه من خلال بعض
المحتوى اللي لا يتوافق اصلا مع طبيعه
المجتمع او يفرض عادات مختلفه
الانتشار الواسع لمتابعه مشاهير مواقع
التواصل بات محطه اهتمام مراكز الدراسات
ففي دراسه نشرتها مجله جورنال
لتحديد اسباب متابعه المشاهير خلصت الى ان
نحو 32 بالمئه منهم يبحثون عن الافكار و
17 بالمئه اخرين عن الالهام والترفيه
فلماذا تبدو المحتويات الجاده اقل انتشارا
[موسيقى]
السريعه وهيك صار انت حتى تقدم يعني
سيناريو انت بتحتاج اقل شيء يعني دقيقه
حتى هالدقيقه معك متاحه لك صار بس يشوفوا
الناس دقيقه ما عاد يتابعوا الفيديو الى
[موسيقى]
المعلومه بطريقه اللي ذكيه واللي تخلي
الناس اللي تسدهم وتقربهم المعلومه ويحس
براسو انه كيستمتع وانه كيتلقى المعلومه
يعني كيجيني ماشي عيب انه كل مره نبغي
نوصل شي حاجه نمشي عند خبير الطبيب عند
باحث عند واحد كيفهم في المجال اللي يزيد
ياكد لي ويصحح لي كاع المعلومات
كلنا عندنا استنساخ في دماغنا وكلنا فينا
بزاف ديال الشخصيات اللي مني كنجمعوهم
كيعطيو الهويه ديال كل واحد فينا
وسائل التواصل التعازل كل عوامل الشهره
وتقدم
الشخصيه المشهوره كانه هو استطاع ان يصبح
مشهورا بين ليله وضحاها وبالتالي بيعيشوا
الشباب اللي بدنا يقلدوه حاله من القلق
ممكن تؤدي الى الاحباط ممكن تؤدي للضياع
في وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي المحتوى
الاكثر رواجا هو المحتوى الذي يتابعه
الناس فلا يمكن وضع قوانين
لهذا المحتوى وانما يجب على المجتمعات
زياده التوعيه وزياده الوعي تجاه هذا
المحتوى واتجاه التعاطي واساليب التعاطي
مع هذا المحتوى وخصوصي انه عم نشوف بعض
الحالات يلي عم يؤثر هذا المحتوى بشكل
سلبي في بعض الاحيان
[موسيقى]
ومع سرعه تطور منصات التواصل الاجتماعي
بات تقييم مخاطرها وفوائدها امرا متغيرا
ففي مقابل غياب الحلول وصعوبه سن قوانين
من شانها ضبط اثار متابعه السوشيال ميديا
ومشاهيرها تبقى الحلول الشخصيه والفرديه
نافذه للاستفاده من ايجابيات مواقع
التواصل كنشر المعرفه والعلوم والتقليل من
سلبياتها
[موسيقى]
نرحب بكم مشاهدينا الكرام وبضيفينا
الكريمين من عمان الدكتور اشرف محمد
الصالحي مستشاره الطب النفسي وعلاج
الادمان ومن بيروت الدكتوره ميل عبد الله
استاذه في علوم الاعلام والاتصال في كليه
الاعلام في الجامعه اللبنانيه رمضان كريم
اهلا بضيفينا الكريمين موضوع شيق يتابع
كثر ليس فقط من الشباب ولكن حتى من الاكبر
سنا وسؤال حقيقه كل هذا الجدد الذي يثار
حول وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي اليس فيه
تجني على الوسيله في حد ذاتها يعني اليست
وسيله بيد الانسان في نهايه الامر يحسن او
يسيء استخدامها وام انها تختلف ربما عن
وسائل الاعلام التقليديه نتذكر جميعا ان
التلفزيون في بداياته كانت هناك احدث جدلا
قنوات
الفضائيه ايضا احدثت جدلا اليس الموضوع
مساله تعود ووقت على هذه الوسائل
والسؤال طبعا موجه لضيف الكريم دكتور اشرف
معليش
سيدتي العزيزه انا رايي من رايك انا رايي
انه هيا وسيله موجوده لنا لنحسن استخدامها
هي والتليفون والتلفزيون والانترنت بشكل
عام المشكله مش فيهم بحد ذاتهم المشكله
فينا احنا لما نستخدمها بشكل خاطئ هنا
تبدا المشكله
فيها الخير وفيها الشر وفيها المواد
المفيده فيها المواد المؤذيه لكن عليك ان
تختار انت ما يناسبك انت او يناسب طفلك او
يناسب قيمك وعاداتك وايضا غير الاختيار
التوقيت كمان نعطيها وقتها الكافي لاي شيء
بنعمله حتى العمل اللي هو فيه عمل الانسان
اذا بيعمله كمان زياده بصير مضر فلازم
يكون في ضابط على المحتوى ضبط على الوقت
وكيفيه استخدامهم وتعليمهم للجيل الحديث
كيف يحموا حالهم من مخاطرها مثل البولينج
من التنمر مثل المشاكل الاخرى
وتتخيلوا هذا العالم زي العالم اللي احنا
عايشينه كما يمكن ان يلتقي الطفل بشخص
غريب وهو في الواقع ممكن كمان يطلع له شخص
غريب بالانترنت او وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي فاحسن ما نحكي انه هي مضره احنا
لازم نعلم اولادنا من مبكرا لانه الان في
في انظمه دراسيه كامله تقوم على استخدام
وسائل السوشيال ميديا وكما حدث عنا احنا
في الاردن في وقت الكورونا عندما تعطل
العالم صارت كل هالدروس والمدارس تشتغل عن
طريق برامج
مايكروسوفت تيمز فلا بد ان يفهم الشخص انه
هذا الشخص اللي مقابل الطفل يفهم الشخص
المقابل هل هو استاذ وفعلا ولا هو شخص
غريب يحاول ان يترتب فيه لياخذ معلومات
منه او هو شخص مؤذي فالتعليم في في
استخدامها هو الذي يحمي ان تكون اشي مؤذيه
مهمه جدا دعني اتحول للدكتوره مي وهي
مختصه في الاعلام والاتصال الدكتوره مي
باعتقادك هل نحن امام وسائل اعلام واتصال
وتواصل مثل التلفزيون كما اشرنا والقنوات
الفضائيه وغيرها من الوسائل اما ان هذه
لها ربما خصوصيه كون اي انسان يمكن ان
يصبح مؤثرا يدلي بدلوه يتابعه الملايين
يعني ليس مرتبطا بعلم ليس مرتبطا بالضروره
بجوده محتوى ليس مرتبطا برساله واضحه ام
انك ترينها في نهايه الامر ربما وسيله
ساهمت في دمقرطت المعلومات
والاتصال مع الجماهير اثبات المتلقي ليس
سلبيا بامكانه ايضا ان ربما يتجاوب مع ما
يتلقاه
نعم مساء الخير
او سعيده بوجودي معكم جدا كنت انا حبيت
كيف انت بداتي بان تحددي ان تسالي ما هي
هذه الوسيله بالنهايه بالنهايه عندما
نتكلم عن وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي نميل ان
نراها مثل بعبع او نراها يعني كان شيء
مفرد المفروض علينا او كاننا
مضطرون لانه نتبعها بشكل اعمى لا هذه
الوسيله هي مجرد اداه هي مجرد وسيله وهي
يعني وراء وراءها طبعا شركات تشغلها
وشركات تسهر على المحتوى وعلى مراقبه
المحتوى ولها مخططاتها ولها اجنده لها
وبالتالي هذه الشركات هي التي تتحكم اليوم
عندما نتكلم عن الديمقراطيه انا تكلمت
واتيت بنظريه المتاهه ونتكلم اليوم عن
متاهات التواصل الاجتماعي
ان هذه الوسيله تاخذنا في كل الاتجاهات
وفيها تتضمن كل الاحتمالات وممكن لاي كان
ان يستخدمها وانا يستخدمها كما يشاء
وبالتالي اذا حكينا عن الديمقراطيه
الديمقراطيه شو هي هي حكم الشعب هل فعلا
الشعب يشارك هل فعلا الشاعر يشارك في
الحكم
بواسطه وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي هل تسهل
عليه المشاركه في الحكم هنا نتساءل عنا
اشكال الانظمه التي لدينا هل تسمح بهذه
المشاركه بالحكم ونسال ثانيه هل القائمون
على هذه
الشركات القائمه على هذه الوسائل التي
تتحكم بالنهايه هل تسمح بهذه الديمقراطيه
وهذه المشاركه الحقيقيه في الحكم وهذه
فعلا الدور الحقيقي للناس وللشعب فدائما
هناك حدود ايضا دائما هناك من يعين ايضا
هناك نوع من المسؤولي يتمتع مستخدموا هذه
الوسائل ايضا بقدر من المسؤوليه ايضا ولا
على هذا ايضا سؤال جوهري تماما اذا
المسؤوليه تقع على الجهات كلها على جهات
التقنيه وعلى جهات الحكوميه وعلى
المستخدمين بدرجه الاولى والاخيره اكيد
بالتاكيد لان المستخدم هو يعرف مصلحته
ولان مستواها ايضا هو يعمل على نفسه يعمل
على تكوين معرفته وطاقاته وبالتالي
مؤهلاته اهل نفسه لاستخدام هذه الوسيله
بشكل واعي بشكل مدرك لمخاطرها وعارف
بمكنوناتها نعم اتحول دكتور اشرف يعني
للناس مذاهب في موضوع التواصل الاجتماعي
وهذه الوسائل كيفيه استخدامها بين من يعني
ربما يتابع هذه الوسائل وبين من يريد ان
يتبع ويصبح مؤثرا بين بين عشيه او ضحاها
او حتى مع الوقت
كما اشرنا في قصتنا الليله وبين ربما من
هو متردد وبين من هو مقاطع بشكل كبير نود
ان نعرف حقيقه يعني ما الذي يحدد توجهات
الناس في هذا الموضوع هل هناك دوافع نفسيه
دوافع شخصيه هي التي تجعل هناك ربما
اختلاف بين الناس في متابعه والانخراط في
هذه الوسائل
انا بحب ااكد على على الدراسات اللي عم
تعرضوها على الشاشه انه فعليا اكثر شيء
نجد انه احنا الاشخاص بيبحثوا عنه في
التكنولوجيا والسوشال ميديا هو الاشياء
اللي فيها ترفيه وضحك ان ذلك بعكس بشكل
غير مباشر الحاله النفسيه التي يعيشها
العالم تمام نحكي على دوله بحد ذاتها
بنحكي على المستوى الكره الارضيه بحد
ذاتها في الركود الاقتصادي الحالي يتبعه
دائما ركود نفسي فبصير في عندي الاشخاص
مشاكل بالقلق اكثر ومعدلات الاكتئاب فعليا
عم تزداد مؤخرا وحتى ناخذ كمان انا بحب
دائما اربطها بالكورونا لانه الفتره هاي
كان فيها دراسات مختلفه على قديش استخدامه
وسائل الاجتماعيه تواصل الاجتماعي قديش
اثر عن نفسيه الانسان فكيف بحددوها
بيحددوها على موضوع انه كيف نجذب الناس
لشيء فني مضحك او شيء يرفه عنهم
اغلبيه اكثر من النصف من المؤثرين بيدخلوا
في هذا النطاق بيدخلوا لهم عن طريق
مسلسلات ترفيهيه ممكن او اسكتشات معينه
فئه تقريبا كمان عشره بالميه تكون العلاقه
في العلم في اشخاص يبحثون عن علم والمعرفه
ويستزيدوا منها وفي كمان الجزء السياسي
الاخباري في كمان الناس عم بتابع الاخبار
حاليا عن طريق السوشيال ميديا احنا زمان
كنا نتابعها على التلفزيون مثل قناه
حضرتكم المبجله الان صارت كل كل انسان معه
تليفون هو زي مثابه صحفي هو ليس صحفي
فعليا لكنه بمثابه الصحفي يصل الى الحدث
بسرعه
ينقل المعلومه فكان الانترنت لهدف الفائده
لهدف خلينا نحكي نشر سياسات معينه ولا
ننسى كمان في الانتخابات الامريكيه التي
حصلت ايام دونالد ترامب قديش كان فيها
مشاكل اقتصاديه وسياسيه وجابوا رئيس
تنفيذي لشركه الفيسبوك انه انت سمحت له
يعني فيها اكثر من رساله بستخدموها
المؤثرين حتى يوصلوا
نعم نعم هو الذي اختار فئه اكبر نعم نعم
بعد انت اشرت الى نقطه مهمه بالفعل
المتعلق بالترفيه عممت ربما بشكل كبير حول
العالم انا اريد ان اخصص هذا البرنامج
موجه بالدرجه الاولى للمشاهد العربي الذي
يتابعنا من بلدان مختلفه خلفيات مختلفه
وسؤالي الان للدكتوره هذا المشاهد العربي
او المتابع الان الذي بات على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي الذي يبحث بدرجه اكبر
في ربما اغلب الحياه عن الترفيه كيف
تقراينه انت هل ذلك مرتبط ربما بالخوف من
الرقابه فيما يخص الامور السياسيه هل
يتعلق الامر بالبيئه الصعبه في غالبيه
دولنا العربيه حروب ماسي الضيق ذات اليد
وغيرها فيهرب من هذا الواقع ان صح التعبير
ويعيش في عالم موازي
انا انا اعتقد
نعم شكرا انا اعتقد ان وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي تغزو حياتنا
وقد غزت حياتنا بشكل بدون ان تستاذن ودخلت
البيوت والمنازل الى حد ما الى حد ان
الاطفال
والشباب هم الاكثر استخداما لهذه الوسائل
وحتى ان هذه الوسيله باتت بين يد الطفل
عمره ست سنين وما فوق وهناك غياب وعي لدى
الاسره ولد الاهل الذين يضعون يسلمون هذه
الوسائل قبل ان يعي الطفل تماما ماذا تخبئ
له وماذا في داخلها وحتى تجاوزنا اليوم
اصبح يعني نقول انه يخلق
ياتي الى الدنيا ومعه
الانترنت معه وسيله التواصل ومعه الفون
الموبايل
ولما خرجت الامور من سيطره الاهل ومن
سيطره المجتمع ككل فانتشرت الى حد كبير
هذه الوسائل التواصل الاجتماعي التي لم
نعود نستطيع
[موسيقى]
التعليم الان مؤسسات التعليميه ايضا ان
تدرج ربما هذه النقطه التوعيه في هذا
الفضاء الذي يمكن ان يكون كغول يفترس
هؤلاء الاطفال
اصبحنا بوقت لم نعد نستطيع ان نتجاهل دور
التوعيه الاعلاميه انه والتربيه الاعلاميه
وكلنا نحن كباحثين نسعى الى هذا الامر
ونجتهد في هذا الامر وحتى ان نحن في
بالرابطه العربيه للبحث العلمي وعلوم
الاتصال نسعى اليوم لدينا مشروع هذه السنه
حول التربيه الى استخدام وسائل الاعلام
والاتصال لانه من الضروري ان نبدا من
الاسره من الطفل ونستمر الى المدرسه الى
الجامعه الى كل جهات المعنيه لابد وان
تكون كلها واعيه لهذه النقطه وتساهم في
التوعيه وتساهم في التعريف خصوصا
والنقل المعرفه بوسائل الاعلام والاتصال
وبمخاطر السوشيال ميديا ومخاطر او بحسنات
ومخاطرها لانها ايضا حسنات فكيف نستخدمها
لخيرنا ونتقي شرها ونلتقي كل مخاطرها التي
قلنا بثنا نعرفها ما هي المخاطر بالنسبه
المراهقين بالنسبه للشباب بالنسبه للاطفال
وبالنسبه لعامه الناس ممتاز هذا معرضون
هذه نقطه مهمه
سرقه كل شيء صحيح للاسف الشديد نتحدث الى
حد الان عن المتلقي وسؤالي الان الدكتور
اشرف ماذا عن المؤثر صانع المحتوى الذي
يقدم هذه الاشياء ماذا عن معاناته ايضا في
هذا الفضاء سمعنا احد المؤثرين يتحدث ربما
عن سطوه المتابعين كيف يصبح هو ربما رهينه
لهؤلاء بتقديم محتوى قد لا يكون دائما
ربما يتوائم مع شخصيته في البدايه يتحول
الى شيء اخر بس فقط جنيا ربما الاعجابات
وبعضهم قد اتخذ وايضا مصدرا للمال
يعني انا المؤثر هو في النهايه هو انسان
بشر مثلنا مثله وهو يقوم في عمله اما
لمنفعه معينه او لانه ليثبت لنفسه انه
يستطيع ان يحصل على ظهور ويكون مشهور او
يقوم بها بحجه انه ايصال معلومه ومعرفه
علميه في انواع مختلفه من المؤثرين هلا
المؤثر خلينا نحكي السليم او الصحيح اذا
صح ذلك التعبير هو الذي يمارس هذه الامور
دون ان يؤثر على صحته العقليه والنفسيه
كيف ذلك كمان ما بتكون حياته فعليا محصوره
وراء الكاميرات وراء شاشه التليفون وراء
الضوء الدائري هو الذي يكون يمارس له
حياته سواء في عمل او مدن عمل ما بنحكي
عنها كو ممكن تكون لانها المؤثر يكون عمله
هو وراء الشاشه فبده يستخدمها كمان هو زي
ما بنطلب المتلقي بحذر وبساعات معينه
المؤثر نفسه كمان بده يستخدمها بحذر
وبساعات معينه وبده يكون اوعى من انه هو
يعتمد على الناس انا بتذكر في فيلم كان
للاطفال بحكي عن عالم النت وبوعيهم وفيلم
جميل جدا
بحضروا دائما انا واولادي اسمه رال فريكس
دي انترنت فبدخل البرتقال البطل على على
قاعه كانه التعليقات وبلاقي في التعليقات
كلها اشياء جارحه هذا المثل الممثل هذا
غبي احنا نكرهه فهاي كمان بتاذيهم
للمؤثرين بحد ذاتهم اذا لم يكن لديه قناعه
بما يعمله وبالذات نتكلم عن فئه والمؤثرين
الصغار في فئه معينه انا بتفرج مرات على
بلاقي في مؤثره صغيره عمرها بجوز 14 و15
سنه مره واحده منهم مصريه شفتها بتبكي من
وراء ردود الافعال عند الاخرين اللي هي
نفس
الوسيله كما ذكرت الدكتوره التي يجب ان تت
فق مع انه يجب
هذه الوسيله ويحسن استخدامها ربما يجب
توعيه رقميه ايضا في هذا الخصوص تبدا من
المدرسه الاعلام والاهل لجميع لديهم
مسؤوليه في هذا الموضوع لكن لنعد للمؤثرين
هم ليسوا ضحايا دائما يعني نتساءل حقيقه
عن المؤثر يعني كيف يمكن يقاس مستوى
التاثير وقد راينا البعض لديه الملايين من
المتابعين لكن
للاسف التاثير الذي يحدثه الدراسات
العلميه هي التي تقول ذلك يصاب من يتابعه
بالاكتئاب بالوحده بعدم تقدير الذات
الفلاتر وما صنعته ببناتنا وبالبنات
المجتمعات العربيه الهوس بعمليات التجميل
الافتراضيه يعني في اقل من ثانيه يتغير
وجه الفتاه ووجه الشاب ويصبح شخص اخر
وبالتالي كيف يمكن ان يقاس هذا التاثير
وكيف يمكن تقنين هذا الموضوع بعض الدول
الغربيه بدات الان في تقنين ضروره وجود
تصاريح لهؤلاء الاشخاص ماذا عن عالمنا
العربي هل هناك تفطن فيما يخص هذه النقطه
نحتاج الى قوانين
نعم دكتور اشرف سعودي
نحتاج الى قوانين من الدول التي يعمل فيها
كل شخص مؤثر وقد بدات الاردن في بلدنا
احنا هون شويه تحط ضوابط وقوانين لمن
يستخدم
وسيله التواصل ويعلن عن نفسه كانه شخص
مؤثر في بعض الضوابط انه المحتوى تبعه
يكون يجب ان يكون عليه نوع من الرقابه حتى
نعرف احنا نقيس ايش المنتج الذي يقدمه
الاعتراض طرق الحاليه للاسف لقياس التاثير
هي اللايكس هي الكومنتات هي الشير
المشاركات هي كم مره صار فيها اذا تويتر
هاي بقيسوا فيها لانه بعطوا فيها مقابل
هذه المشاهدات وهذه الارقام مبلغ مالي
للمؤثر نفسه اما اذا احنا نقيس من نهايه
الخط احنا مستوى التاثير الذي يتركه
بالفرد اذا كان الشخص بيقدم محتوى كوميدي
فكم السعاده التي تركها في قلوب المتابعين
له ببراءته بمحتوى الجميل النظيف اذا
كانوا يقدم محتوى علمي بكميه العلم
التغيرات في في طريقه تفكير المتابعين
تبعونه فهي جدا صعب قياسها بهذا الشكل
العلمي احنا لانه نقيس انه الشخص نفسه شو
غير فبدنا نعرف الموضوع هذا للفئه
المتوسطه بالعمر او الكبيره او الصغيره
خاصه بهذا الشخص نعم اعود اليك الان بهذا
السؤال وهو مهم يعني طرح على نطاق واسع
على من تقع مسؤوليه ربما ضبط هذا الموضوع
الشركات لديها يعني مصالحها في هذا
الموضوع الشركات المالكه لوسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي يعني من باعتقادك بيده امكانيه
تقنين هذا الموضوع بطريقه تحمي الاصغر سنا
لكن حتى من البالغين الذين باتت تتاثر
صحتهم النفسيه والعقليه حتى بهذه
المحتويات بالتنمر على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي
بالانتقادات التي يمكن ان يصدرها ايا كان
يعني الاشخاص يعني بكل عقادهم ربما
ومشاكلهم النفسيه يصدرونها ويضعون يبثون
للاسف هذه السموم على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي
نعم هذا مرتبط ايضا موضوع الديمقراطيه
يعني
عندما نقول من نحن لا نطلب
ان يكون هناك نوع من
القمع او نوع من
التفرد يعني ان يكون هناك جهات توقف وتمنع
وتراقب نحن لا نطالب المراقبه المباشره
هكذا ولكن في نفس الوقت ليس خطا ابدا بان
توضع بعض الحدود مثل ما تفعل الان دوله
الامارات العربيه هي التي مثلا بالنسبه
الدعايات بالنسبه يعني وضعت بعض الشروط
الهامه بالنسبه للمؤثرين ان ياخذوا رخصه
انا اجدها اجده حل ان نعطي رخصه لهؤلاء
المؤثرين يتميزوا عن بقيه المؤثرين الذين
ليسوا مؤثرين بمعنى الكلمه يعني ان ربما
يؤثرون بطريقه خاطئه او بطريقه الهابطه او
بطريقه ولكن هناك هنا نعود الى متاهه
حقيقيه انه من يقرر موضوع المتاهه التفاهه
ومن يقرر موضوع الاخلاقيات من يقول هذا
اخلاقي وهذا غير اخلاقي هذا جيد او غير
جيد هنا هذا الحكم ولذلك نعود لنقول انه
فعلا عندما نرى من يؤثر اليوم المؤثرون
حقيقيون هم الذين يتعبون على انفسهم هناك
مثلا اعطي مثل مستر بيستر هذا مؤثر كبير
هو الاكثر مؤثرين اعتقد انه اكثر المؤثرين
شهره وقد جنى الاموال طائله من شهرته واثر
كثيرا واكثر يعني اكبر المؤثرين هذا شاب
بسيط ماذا يفعل يوزع هدايا وعن طريق
ادعايات وتوزيع الهدايا جلست ثلاث سنين مع
اصدقائه يراقبون ويدرسون بدقه فهذا اعطى
عمره يعني هذا هوس مهووس بهذا بهذا الامر
فنرى المؤثر المهووس فعلا الذي يريد ان
يجني المال ويصبح غنيا فبالنهايه المؤثرين
هدفهم ربما البعض قليل ولكن الهدف الاساسي
هو جميع المال وهو الربح والمنافسه اليوم
الاساسيه هي ثوب الربح ان نربح وان نكون
متواجدين بقوه
فنجزم الدعايات ونجذب وناخذ جوائز من
اليوتيوب واعتراف من اليوتيوب ومن تيك توك
ومن هذه
الابلكيشنز من هذه الوسائل فاذا هذه هي
التطبيقات هي تكافئ هذا الرجل الذي استطاع
ان يجز اليه الاف الناس باعطائهم وتوزيعه
عليهم المال والهدايا فصنع اليوتيوب صنع
افلام يوتيوب ومن خلال اليوتيوب اصبح غنيا
جدا جدا
للاسف شديد الدكتور
وغيره لا نريد ان نخصص لكن هذا هو النموذج
والرساله للاسف التي تعطى لابنائنا في
بعدم تقديس العمل الاجتهاد التعب الكلل
العلم يعني اصبح ما هو المال السريع المال
الذي ياتي بتقديم محتوى يختلف او يتفق
حوله البعض بطريقه سهله بات هذا هو
النموذج للاسف الذي يتبعه كثر اتحول دكتور
اشرف دكتور
مهمه جدا من يضع هذا السلم سلم القيم يعني
الجميع على الاقل نتفق على خطوط عريضه
نقاط عريضه في مجتمعاتنا العربيه والمسلمه
في هذه المنطقه مبدا الستر مبدا عدم
الايذاء ولو بكلمه مبدا عدم التدخل في
شؤون الاخرين يعني كل هذه الامور موجوده
في موروثنا الثقافي والديني في المنطقه
وهي تنتهك بشكل كبير وصارخ الان على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي والسؤال كيف يؤثر ذلك
على سلم قيم المجتمع ما الذي احدثه في
مجتمعاتنا العربيه والمسلمه
الواقع هو مثل الغزو كما بلشنا احنا
برنامجنا بنحكي هو فعلا غزو ولسه القادم
للاسف انا يعني شوي هيك
متشكك من القادم فتره الفي ار واللي بصار
العالم الافتراضي يعيش في داخله الانسان
وهلا الذكاء الاصطناعي وصحبه الانسان مع
الاله هذا هذا المستقبل الذي سوف ينتظرون
خلال العشر سنوات ربما اعتقد حيخفف كثير
من العلاقات الاجتماعيه الحقيقيه اللي هي
اساس خلينا نحكي السعاده اساس راحه البال
في المجتمع والفرد والعائله فكيف اثر على
القيم اثر بشكل كبير جدا في ناس ما كانت
تعرف بعض الحقائق عن بلدان اخرى فصاروا
يعرضوا برامجهم ومسلسلاتهم في كل تلفون او
كل ايباد في البيت لطفل معين فصارت
الثقافه الغربيه او الشرقيه متبادله مع
الجميع فاصبح العالم قريه صغيره كانوا
يحكوها هذه الجمله عندما طلع الانترنت
هلا مع تقدم وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
فكانه صنفوها انترنت جوا الانترنت فاحنا
عم نتعمق اكثر قاعدين في التكنولوجيا
ونبتعد اكثر عن انسانيتنا وقيمنا هون انا
بحكي ثلاث مراحل هون مرحله المؤثر نفسه
لازم يحط ضوابطه وقيمه البرنامج اللي
بنستخدمه احنا في تقديم الوسيله هاي كمان
عندهم ضوابط معينه للمحتوى والاخير الاهم
اللي في يدنا احنا نتحكم فيه المتلقي هو
هو لازم يعرف يختار المحتوى الاطفال يجب
ان لا يدخلوا لبرامج زي الفيسبوك وزي زي
الانستغرام حتى لما نسوي احنا دخول تسجيل
لمشترك جديد بساله عن العمر هلا في بعض
الاهالي بحطوا اطفالهم باعمار كبيره عشان
يسمحوا لهم يمارسوهم فانت بتعرض ايها الاب
او الام هذا الطفل لما تسجل عمره 18 سنه
وطالع وهو عمره فعليا عشر سنوات انت
بتعرضه وانت لا تدري لمناظر قد لا تكون
خادشه للحياه فقط بس لثقافات الاشياء اكبر
من عقله فتاتي لاحقا وتلوم التكنولوجيا
وانت الذي اخطات
هلا نحن نتكلم ايضا عن سؤال بانها فتره
انتقاليه ولكن نتسائل ان كانت فتره
انتقاليه الى متى يعني هل هي فتره
انتقاليه فعلا اما نحن ام هي يتكلم يعني
طبعا العلماء عن مثلا نهايه التاريخ او
نهايه الانسان بمعنى انه انتهى هذه اخر
مرحله من التنظير يعني هناك نظريه
الديمقراطيه الليبراليه هي النظريه
الاخيره في هذا الزمن ويتكلمون عن نهايه
الانسان بمعنى انه الانسان لن يعود
الانسان نفسه فنرى انسانا جديدا ومجتمعات
جديده وعالم جديد
فاتنبا بعالم جديد بالتاكيد واتنبا اكيد
بالتاكيد بانسان اخر الانسان ليس الانسان
هو نفسه
حتى لما من يولد اليوم عندما سيكون بعمري
لن يكون نفس الانسان بالتاكيد بالتاكيد
سيكون انسان اخر امامه
واجدادنا بالفعل الانسان في حاله تطور
نتمنى لا لا
وان اتفضلي عندك فكره اسرع بكثير
على القيم اكبر بكثير والتحديات على اداره
الوقت والتحديات على اقامه علاقات غير
العلاقات التي على الانترنت يجب ان نحافظ
على حياتنا الاجتماعيه ولا ان تكون حياتنا
الاجتماعيه كلها في المجتمعات الالكترونيه
نحن نتحول الى مجتمعات رقميه
ونتخلى عن مجتمعنا الاصلي لعله فعلا هذا
هو التحدي اليوم تحديات المستقبل القريب
امامنا جميعا كاشخاص وامام الانسانيه جمع
ليس في منطقتنا فقط اشكرك جزيل الشكر
الدكتوره
علوم الاعلام والاتصال في كليه الاعلام في
الجامعه اللبنانيه كما اشكر جزيل الشكر
ضيفنا من عمان دكتور اشرف محمد الصالحي
مستشار طب النفسي وعلاج الادمان
ختم هذه الحلقه نعود ونلقاكم باذن الله
الاثنين القادم مع بقيه لقصه جديده دمتم
في رعايه الله والسلام عليكم
[موسيقى]